nick fury
that's what he would sing he would just
sing his name
welcome to another episode of what's up
disney plus
where we talk all things disney plus
jenny the holidays are here so cozy up
in front of the arendelle yule log
because we've got the perfect lineup for
the holiday season
we're a pirouette and plie away from the
new disney plus
original series on point just like that
that's on point very on point and we'll
be channeling our inner vision
to phase through every marvel studios
film on disney plus
all of them judy
let's do it we're doing a saute
into disney's newest original series
about the year in the life of ballet
students
at the prestigious school of american
ballet in new york city
as they prepare for the nutcracker andre
you got any uh
ballet moves you want to show the folks
at home well i did take
one dance class in college so i remember
there was a little bit you like you
would peel your leg
and you point your toe and then you like
try to spin that was about as far as i
could go at this point
very beautiful like a swan i feel like a
duckling
but i will say it is a challenge to have
to do something like that to have your
toe point a certain way
have your arms out perfection is key so
to have to go through the audition
process to then be chosen to go through
all of the training to then be chosen to
go through the actual show and
performance that is all
very impressive extremely impressive i
mean like you andre
i took one year of dance oh
and that was it it's not easy
so much much respect to these talented
students
yes as they say in the theater bravo and
now
hold on to your tutus because we've got
a sneak peek coming at you
brought to you by our friends at geico
where bundling is made easy
visit geico.com
at first when i joined ballet as a
seven-year-old i thought
everyone i saw in the ballet they were
so formal so they must be in real life
but that's not the case if i have a claw
that's not right you know a locked
little claw it has to just be in the
right place
my first ballet memory was good
nutcracker
i got into school of american ballet by
my parents taking me to see the
nutcracker
like in new york city ballet i saw a
little
snippet it says if you want to be in
this show
the kids who are performing are at the
school of american ballet
so break out those leotards point those
toes and stream
on point starting on disney plus
tomorrow and now here's what's new
the arendelle castle ulog is returning
tomorrow
the castle is newly decorated this year
with elements harking back
to anna elsa olaf kristoff and spends
recent journey
to the enchanted forest in frozen 2.
marvel studios legends is a new series
that revisits some of the most
iconic moments from the mcu one
character at a time
kicking off with one in maximoff and
vision the first two episodes start
streaming january 8th
only on disney plus gotta love this news
earl
baby and the rest of the sinclair fam
are coming to disney plus
start streaming dinosaurs on january
29th
glorious loki an original series from
marvel studios
is coming may 2021 to disney plus check
out an exclusive clip over on the disney
plus instagram
at disney plus the marvel cinematic
universe created
23 films over the course of 12
years jenny what are some of your
favorite mcu films
thor ragnarok end game guardians of the
galaxy
and hold on black panther oh my gosh
ant-man sorry there's a lot
are there any movies left it is hard to
choose and i've had to think about this
for
quite a bit oh my gosh hello captain
america civil war okay i'll stop
you basically named my entire dvd
collection just now
that's really great i agree with all
those movies particularly for me captain
america the winter soldier i don't think
he mentioned that one so i'll throw that
one in there and yes
of course black panther was amazing i
saw that movie i think
four times in the theater and that first
iron man just started off strong
leading up to infinity war in game it's
just an amazing story amazing journey
that we've gone through so far
with still more to come so before the
release of marvel studios one division
which premieres on january 15th
we wanted to catch you all up in quinjet
speed on all of the marvel studios films
on disney plus
warning there will be some spoilers in
this
okay andre are you ready whatever it
takes
iron man genius billionaire
philanthropist builds an arc director in
a cave
restarts his heart makes a cool suit and
kicks off the mcu
tony takes on an electric whip wielding
evan banco who loves his bird
the god of thunder ends up getting
banished to earth but his brother loki
just ruins everything like brothers do
steve rogers takes a super soldier serum
and then he takes on hydra and then he
gets frozen for 70 years he's like a
human popsicle and he wakes up for
avengers where they all team up to fight
loki to get the tesseract off of earth
so many
iron man suits all the feelings throw
the dark world the dark elves are coming
for asgard and jane has
the ether inside of her body which is
one of the stones cap joins forces with
shield and then finds out that his best
friend bucky barnes is actually alive
but he's also a mind controlled assassin
it's a lot peter quill and the team of
misfits get the power stone
it has an epic soundtrack and even ends
off with a dance battle the avengers
reassemble to take on a self-aware
villain bot named ultron vision's in
that too
ant-man x-con fine suit tricks from the
size of an ant
and fights a villain ants
it's cap versus iron man because the
winter soldier's actions
force the heroes to pick sides
neurosurgeon dr steven strange loses the
use of his hands in an accident seeks
the ancient one
and also it's really trippy peter quill
reunites with his terrible father and
yandu discovers his inner mary poppins i
married poppins y'all
thornton's friend for work hulk battle
out and thor and loki's long little
sister
comes up and races some evil t'challa
the black panther takes on the mantle as
king
and he battles killmonger for the
kingdom of wakanda forever avengers
infinity war all the avengers team up
against thanos who's collecting all the
stones
and once he does that snap mr stark i
don't feel so good
i'm sad okay hope van dyne becomes wasp
and she and ant-man team up to find her
mother who is lost in the quantum realm
and then she gets distracted by a ghost
captain marvel in the 90s in a battle
between the cree and the scrolls can
change in any form they want to while
she discovers her past as air force
pilot carol davis
okay this is the ultimate showdown to
take down thanos and everyone and i mean
everyone assembles and we did it we
assembled
all these films together talk about
going higher further faster baby i mean
we must have broken a record
i know well we could do this all day but
to get the full story for yourself make
sure you stream all the marvel films on
disney plus
b4 marvel studios one division drops on
january 15th
21 i cannot wait to see one division so
excited
all right that's it for today i think
it's time for us to retire our ballet
shoes for good
yup i'm ready to take a big ol nap
because that challenge was exhausting
be sure to like comment subscribe and
share this video and head on over to
disney plus
where you can stream all of your
favorites and more
and tune in next time where you can see
our ballet interpretation of the mcu
this is my hawkeye oh this is my scarlet
witch
she's a flamenco dancer
i am inevitable
[Music]
you